on the evening of august 5th 2012
pacific daylight time nasa's mars rover
named curiosity
entered mars atmosphere at 20 000
kilometers per hour
drag slowed it down to around sixteen
hundred kilometers per hour at which
point a parachute opened
this parachute slowed the rover more to
about 320 kilometers per hour or 90
meters per second finally after rockets
decelerated it completely the rover was
lowered to the surface of mars
every step of this dance was carefully
choreographed and rehearsed in many
experiments here on earth but how could
nasa engineers be sure that their
designs would work on a totally
different planet
the answer is a problem-solving method
called dimensional analysis
this video is part of the
problem-solving video series
problem-solving skills in combination
with an understanding of the natural and
human-made world are critical to the
design and optimization of systems and
processes
hi my name is ken cameron and i'm a
professor of mechanical engineering at
mit
dimensional analysis is a powerful tool
i use it nasa uses it and you will too
before watching this video you should be
familiar with unit analysis
and understand the difference between
dependent and independent variables
by the end of this video you will be
able to use dimensional analysis to
estimate the size of a parachute canopy
that can slow the rover down to 90
meters per second on its descent to mars
before we talk about dimensional
analysis we need to know what dimension
is
dimensions and units are related but
different concepts
physical quantities are measured in
units
the dimension of the physical quantity
is independent of the particular units
chosen for example
both grams and kilograms are units but
they are units of mass
and mass is what we'll call the
dimension
there are five fundamental dimensions
that we commonly deal with
length
mass
time
temperature and charge
all other dimensions are obtained by
taking products and powers of these
fundamental dimensions
in this video we'll be dealing with
length which we denote by the letter l
mass denoted by m
and time t
for example
no matter how you measure the physical
quantity velocity it has the dimension
which we denote with square brackets
of length divided by time or length
times time to the negative one power
pause the video here and determine the
dimension of energy
energy has dimension
mass times length squared over time
squared
okay great
so what's the big deal how is this
useful
remember nasa's rover
part of the landing sequence calls for a
parachute to slow the vehicle down
suppose it is our job to design the
parachute to slow the rover to exactly
90 meters per second
the terminal velocity of the rover
depends on the mass of the rover itself
and its heat shield
and several different variables related
to the parachute design
the material of the canopy
the diameter of the hemispherical
parachute canopy the number of
suspension lines etc
for simplicity let's suppose that all
parachute parameters other than the
diameter of the canopy have already been
determined
our goal is to find the canopy diameter
that is as small as possible but will
correspond to the desired terminal
velocity of 90 meters per second
clearly we can't test our designs on
bars
the question is
how can we get meaningful data here on
earth that will allow us to
appropriately size the parachute for use
on mars
how do we predict the behavior of a
parachute on mars based on an earth
experiment and what variables do we need
to consider in designing our experiment
on earth
this is where a problem-solving method
called dimensional analysis can help us
before we get started we must first
determine what the dependent and
independent variables are in our system
the dependent variable
is terminal velocity
this is the quantity that we wish to
constrain by our parachute design
so what variables affect the terminal
velocity of the parachute in the rover
system
the diameter of the parachute canopy is
one such independent variable take a
moment to pause the video and identify
others
okay here's our list
canopy diameter
mass of the rover
we assume the mass of the parachute to
be negligible
acceleration due to gravity
and the density and viscosity of the
atmosphere
for this problem we can assume that the
dependence of the terminal velocity on
atmospheric viscosity is negligible
because the atmosphere on mars like the
atmosphere on earth is not very viscous
if we wanted to derive a functional
relationship that would work for example
underwater it would be important that we
include viscosity as an independent
variable
why didn't we include the surface area
of the parachute canopy in our list of
independent variables
pause the video and take a moment to
discuss with a classmate
we didn't include the surface area of
the canopy because it is not independent
from the diameter of the canopy
in fact we can determine the area as a
function of diameter so we don't need
both
question
could we use the surface area instead of
the diameter
absolutely
we need the variables to be independent
but it doesn't matter which variables we
use
the key is to have identified all of the
correct variables to begin with
this is where human error can come into
play if our list of variables isn't
exhaustive the relationship we develop
through dimensional analysis may not be
correct
once we have the full list of
independent variables we can express the
terminal velocity as some function of
these independent variables
in order to find the function that
describes the relationship we need to do
several experiments involving four
independent variables and fit the data
that's a lot of work
especially because we don't know what
the function might look like
but whenever you have an equation all
terms in the equations must have the
same dimension
multiplying two terms multiplies the
dimensions
this restricts the possible form that a
function describing the terminal
velocity in terms of our four other
variables can take
because the function must combine the
variables in some way that has the same
dimension as velocity
and many functions
exponential logarithmic trigonometric
cannot have input variables that have
dimension
what would e to the one kilogram mean
what units could it possibly have
we're going to show you a
problem-solving method that will allow
you to find the most general form of
such a function
this method is called dimensional
analysis
we begin this process by creating
dimensionless versions of the variables
in our system
we create these dimensionless
expressions out of the variables in our
system so we don't introduce any new
physical parameters
the first step is to take our list of
variables and distill them down to their
fundamental dimensions
remember our fundamental dimensions are
length mass and time
distilling gravity to its fundamental
dimension we get length per time squared
now you distill the remaining variables
of velocity diameter mass and density
into their fundamental dimensions
pause the video here
velocity is length per time diameter is
length mass is mass
and density is mass per length cubed
the second step is to express the
fundamental dimensions of mass length
and time in terms of our variables
we can write m as little m
we can write l
as mass divided by density to the
one-third power
we can write t as velocity divided by
gravity we had many choices as to how to
write these fundamental dimensions in
terms of our variables
in the end it doesn't matter which
expressions you choose
the third step is to use these
fundamental dimensions to turn all of
the variables involved into
dimensionless quantities
for example
the terminal velocity v has dimension of
length over time
so we multiply v
by the dimension of time
and divide by the dimension of length
to get a dimension of 1.
we define a new dimensionless variable v
bar as this dimensionless version of v
now you try
find d-bar
m-bar
g-bar
and row bar
pause the video here
you should have found that d bar is d
times rho over m to the one third
m bar is one
g bar is v squared over g times rho over
m to the one third
and rho bar is one
now we can rewrite the equation for
velocity in terms of the new
dimensionless variables
it is a new function because the
variables have been modified
notice that v bar is equal to g bar
this means that v bar and g bar
are not independent
so our function for v bar
cannot depend on g bar
also notice that m bar and rho bar are
both equal to 1
so our function doesn't depend on them
either
this has simplified our relationship
v bar is a function of only one variable
d bar
and remember that d bar is dimensionless
so it's just a real number
this means that phi
can be any function
the fourth and final step is to
rearrange to find a formula for the
terminal velocity
the key here is that the equation for
the terminal velocity has the correct
dimension
and this formula is so general that any
expression with dimension of length over
time can be written in terms of this
formula by defining fee in different
ways
let's see how
first create an expression from the
independent variables that has the same
dimension as velocity
one such expression is the square root
of g times d
by setting the formula for v
equal to the square root of g d
we see that by setting phi equal to the
identity function
phi of x equals x
the two sides of the equation can be
made equal
and in fact we claim that any expression
with the correct dimension of length
over time created using these variables
can be written in terms of this formula
simply by changing the definition of fee
it can be fun to try this
come up with different formulas that
have the correct dimension
you can even add them together when
you're done then see if you can find a
way to define fee so that our formula is
equal to the expression you wrote
pause the video here
now you may be concerned because this
formula is not unique
we made some choices about how to
represent our fundamental dimensions
what happens if we make different
choices
here we chose m
l and t
this way
m was little m
l was little d
and t was v over g
running through the dimensional analysis
process with this choice of fundamental
dimensions we obtain an equation for v
that looks like this
to see that these two formulas are
equivalent we set the arguments under
the square root equal and find that we
can express phi as a function of psi
so
any formula with the correct dimension
can be expressed by this general formula
and this general formula works for any
rover on any planet whose terminal
velocity through the atmosphere depends
on the same variables because it's a
general law
of course we still don't know what this
function phi is
in order to find phi we can fit
experimental data from any planet for
example
earth
on earth we know the gravity and
atmospheric density we can specify the
mass of a test rover to be
10 kilograms
then we might set up earthbound
experiments by varying the canopy
diameter of a parachute between 1 meter
to 20 meters and measuring the terminal
velocity
for example suppose we obtain the
following data on earth
then we could convert this data to the
d-bar v-bar axes by scaling the
variables v and d
according to the earth values for the
mass gravity and atmospheric density
we can fit this data to some best fit
curve and this best fit curve is our
best approximation to that function phi
now that we have phi
we can transform the axes again to
represent the canopy diameter and
terminal velocity on mars
this is done by converting v bar and d
bar
to v and d by scaling according to known
values of the gravity atmospheric
density and mass of the rover on mars
to find the diameter we find the point
on the v axis
that corresponds to a terminal velocity
of 90 meters per second
and use our curve to determine the
diameter that corresponds to this
terminal velocity
now we have the specification we need to
design the size of our parachute to be
used on the descent to
mars in this example we use dimensional
analysis to restrict the possible form
of a function describing the terminal
velocity of the mars rover
as a function of the parachute canopy
diameter
gravitational acceleration atmospheric
density and the mass of the rover
this allowed us to design a parachute
for use on mars based on earth-bound
experiments
in general the process of dimensional
analysis involves
one
identifying the dependent variable and
independent variables
two
expressing the relevant fundamental
dimensions in terms of the variables
found in step one
three generating dimensionless
expressions for all the variables using
expressions from step two
four producing a functional relationship
between the dimensionless dependent
variable in terms of the remaining
independent dimensionless expressions
five
rearranging to determine a formula for
the variable of interest
and six performing experiments to
determine the form of the general real
valued function that appears in that
formula
we've just shown you a very powerful
tool which can save you a lot of time
so the next time you're faced with a
difficult challenge you might just want
to try dimensional analysis
you